on pas ce que vivent les enfants face au
harcellement faites le
[Musique]
3018 allez on va la tourner tout le
monde en place et action Michel regardez
votre programme avec Yoni et Michel
PAREF qui ne serait pas là s'il avait
mieux géré son épargne et je fais quoi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débat de
chronique et de reportage 90 minutes
pour donner du sens à l'actualité vous
proposer des clés de compréhension des
mutations de notre société et voici le
sommaire de ce 28 novembre plus de 6
Français sur 10 souhaitent le départ
d'Élisabeth borne de Matignon et 71 %
d'entre eux pensent qu'elle ne ferait
pas non plus une bonne tête de liste aux
élections européennes notre notre
baromètre politique de novembre n'est
pas tendre pour la première ministre
alors que des rumeurs de remanement
repartent depu belle qui est le mieux
placé pour la remplacer Emmanuel Macron
peut-il changer d'équipe dès le mois de
janvier quel impact le conflit Israël
Hamas mais aussi les faits divers récent
ont sur l'opinion on en débat dans une
minute et puis pour notre second thème
je vous propose l'histoire d'une réforme
difficile à mettre en œuvre la
légalisation de l'euthanasie on a
assisté jusqu'à la fin euh de ville
maman donc on était tous autour d'elle
quand le médecin a a pratiqué euh enfin
en tout cas a fait la piqûre
l'étal
et c'était tellement paisible parce que
dans un premier temps elle s'endort et
puis et puis le cœur
s'arrête près de 9 Français sur 10
souhaitent légaliser l'euthanasie
c'était une promesse de campagne du
candidat Macron et pourtant le Président
de la République hésite pourquoi un tel
flottement alors que le projet de loi
existe il est écrit que changerait
précisément cette réforme comment cette
pratique est-elle encadrée notamment en
Belgique réponse dans trois quart
d'heure mais d'abord les enseignements
du baromètre odoxa mascaré pour Public
Sénat et les journaux de la presse
quotidienne régional on commence avec
les personnalités politiques préférées
des Français Jonathan dupriz c'est l'un
des principaux enseignements de notre
baromètre odoxa pour public sénna publié
aujourd'hui dans un contexte
international tendu notamment avec le
conflit Israël Hamas des responsables
politiques de premier plan gagnent en
popularité porté par l'effet drapeau à
commencé par Édouard Philippe l'ancien
Premier ministre donné comme
présidentiable possible pour 2027
caracole en tête du classement avec 44 %
d'opinion favorable il est quand même
maire évidemment d'une ville moyenne
plus mais relativement importante il
arrive aussi à toujours avoir une parole
justement présidentiable si je puis dire
c'est-à-dire on ne Cliffe pas trop on
rassure et on est toujours un peu
au-dessus derrière lui deux
personnalités se détachent execo Marine
Le Pen et Gabriel Atal atteignent 38 %
de code d'adhésion ABA dans les écoles
attentat à haras les sujets délicats de
la rentrée ont porté le jeune ministre
de l'éducation nationale au tout premier
plan de l'attention médiatique on a un
Gabriel qui n'était pas non plus
extrêmement connu avant d'arriver à
l'éducation nationale or il y a un effet
évidemment nous qui sommes dans le je
dirais dans le la vie politique qui
connaiss son ça on a trèsôt identifié
que et bien Gabriel Atal pouvait être un
pilier de la macronie l'autre élément
c'est qu'il a su extrêmement bien jouer
sur les outils de communication
parallèlement le couple exécutif semble
être en inversion de phase d'un côté
Emmanuel Macron en surplomb avec les
crises internationales gagne 5 points de
popularité en 6 mois pour atteindre 35 %
d'opinion favorable toutefois ellisabeth
bornne plus exposée en politique
intérieure semble ptir d'un des aux
portant de l'opinion 69 % des sondés
jugent qu'elle est une mauvaise premire
ministre on a toujours la volonté pour
le président de la République de mettre
un Premier ministre qui joue à la fois
le rôle de paratonnaire et en même temps
le rôle de fusible et donc évidemment
dès le moment où la situation politique
se gade dès le moment où vous avez des
tensions sociales dans le pays et bien
le Premier ministre prend dès lors qu'il
est mis en avant autre renseignement à
gauche Jean-Luc Mélenchon plonge dans
l'opinion avec seulement 18 % de code
d'adhésion au cœur de polémique ces
dernières semaines notamment son refus
de considér le Hamas comme organisation
terroriste l'ancien candidat à
l'élection présidentielle voit son
leadership à gauche s moussé de mois en
mois et on détaille les résultats de
notre baromètre avec Céline bra bonsoir
directrice générale deodxa bienvenue à
vous Sophie Coignard bonsoir et
bienvenue vous êtes journaliste
éditorialiste politique au point Mathieu
souquer bonsoir et bienvenue consultant
etci spécialisé en sciences politique on
est également en duplexe avec Yv San
seior partner chez mascar bonsoir y et
latia crupa éditorialiste politique
bonsoir latia bienvenue à vous on
commence par l'ancien Premier ministre
Édouard Philippe si vous le voulez bien
c'est line brac comment expliquer ce
cette régularité au au sommet est-ce que
c'est la rareté de sa parole qu'il sert
également oui alors pas seulement
c'està-dire qu'il a une personnalité qui
même lorsqu'il était Premier Ministre
faisait de lui une personnalité
apprécier il était il il avait un une
code de personnalité haute pour un
premier ministre h est stable dans le
temps alors la stabilité c'est pas
toujours le cas parce que sur le
baromètre politique on a vu notamment
que pendant la période des retraites et
bien comme les ministres en poste et
bien Édouard Philippe qui n'était
pourtant pas comment dire en ligne de
front sur ce
sujet voilà mais il il il a été
considéré par l'opinion comme un soutien
de cette réforme extrêmementpulaire il a
perdu beaucoup de terrain puis depuis
tout le monde remonte et Philippe qui
est en tête maintenant depuis des mois
et bien on remonte lui aussi maintenant
il faut quand même se méfier de ce petit
effet Simon veille Bernard couchner vous
voyez qui était très très haut de de des
baromètres politiques de Paris Match
pendant très longtemps parce que
précisément ils étaient quand même hop
un pas derrière les autres un peu en
retraitah pas complètement justement de
sur la politique nationale et donc euh
il faut voir ce qui va se passer quand
si il le souhaite d'ailleurs s'il
devient à nouveau un représentant
politique national et qu'il veut se
présenter par exemple à la prochaine
présiden has à la présidentielle Sophie
coigner est-ce que vous trouvez des
points communs entre les les les trois
personnalités on va revoir le le le le
baromètre les trois personnalité qui
arrivve sur le bonhum et Édouard
Philippe on l'a dit et gabrielal Marine
Le Pen exéo à 38 % d'opinions favorable
ces trois-là quel point commun si si on
doit retrouver bah s'il faut retrouver
je dirais que leur point commun surtout
dans l'actualité c'est ces dernières
semaines euh c'est qu'ils ont parlé cach
euh si je puis dire c'est-à-dire que ils
sont exprimés de façon euh ils n'ont pas
euh refuser l'obstacle du clivage voilà
pour le dire autrement euh bon Marine Le
Pen de toute façon elle est dans son
rôle c'està-dire bon certes des
diabolisations mais enfin quand même il
faut continuer à à à tracer en parlant
en parlant fort euh et Gabriel Atal
évidemment c'est c'est la grande
surprise la grande vedette de cette
rentrée politique dans la majorité on
voit bien que il peut dire qu'il parle
le cach bah il ne mâche pas ses mots
c'est-à-dire euh ni il ne mche ses mot
si vous enfin je veux dire les questions
au Gouvernement sont un exercice dans
lequel il il y va très fort où il refuse
jamais y compris de pointer ses
adversaires politiques du doigt je pense
notamment à la France insoumise et puis
euh même sur les sujets abordés un
ministre de l'éducation qui en l'espace
de 2 semaines dit qu'éventuellement on
va va on va faire des groupes de niveau
et qu'on va réfléchir à redonner un peu
d'importance au
redoublement normalement c'est ce qui
s'appelle du suicide rue de Grenelle
parce le clerger le clerger pédagogique
n'est pas absolument enchanté par ce
genre de chos donc là ils doivent être
en train d'ter de rage mais néanmoins
Gabriel Atal s'est affranchi de tout
cela ça veut dire que ça plaît à
l'opinion publique ça plaît à l'opin ça
plat à l'opinion alors j'allais en venir
à ça mais alors SV de contrôle et et
quant à Édouard Philippe je pense que sa
prise de position sur la guerre entre
Israël Israël et le Hamas notamment en
disant écoutez excusez-moi mais une
guerre c'est une guerre et ça fait des
morts c'est moche mais c'est comme ça je
résume mais c'était la avait rappelé
notamment ce qui le le le le dessin de
sa ville du Havre pendant la seconde
Guer tout à fait tout à fait et bien est
une position qui tranche notamment par
rapport à celle un peu fluctuante du
président de la République donc voilà ce
que j' appelle par les caches et je
pense qu'évidemment c'est apprécié par
une opinion publique qui est
majoritairement en quête d'autorité
c'est je pense que vous montre toutes
les enquêtes d'opinion il y a il y a un
autre élément une autre leçon qu'on peut
tirer Mathieu souquer quand on revoit là
ce ces cinq premiers en tout cas il y a
c'est un match majorité présidentielle
rassemblement national euh oui alors ce
match ce match là est installé depuis
longtemps moi pardon je me par un petit
petit complément je je je comprends pas
bien en fait le la petite surcôte
d'Édouard Philippe et même globalement
alors je je c'est un c'est un homme
politique qui a des d'incontestable
qualité il a géré la crise sanitaire en
particulier avec un certain talent il
n'empêche que en terme de sens politique
on se souvient que il est sorti de
Matignon avec une côte de popularité
très élevée alors que on a quand même en
tête qu'il a conseillé à plusieurs
reprises au président de la République
et plus que conseillé il a réussi à
convaincre le Président de la République
d'un certain nombre de décisions qui
sont assez mal passer dans le pays la
limitation de vitesse à 80 km/h c'était
pas un carton plein euh c'est l'un des
facteurscl et puis même un certain
nombre de de de décisions qui auraient
pu être prises pendant le covid
précisément confinement prolongé et
cetera je dirais que de ce point de
vue-là il est assez le le fils spirituel
de son père politique à savoir Alain
Jupé c'est une capacité alors un
quelqu'un d'incontestablement compétent
avec une forme d'or de charisme et de
culture mais avec quand même une
capacité de temp en temps à ne pas
totalement
saisir attention popularité
potentiellement friable c'est ça je je
en tout cas à ce stade elle ne s'effrite
pas mais je à titre personnel elle me
questionne et puis sur sur les deux
qu'on évoquait pardon Gabriel Atal il
est précisément au pouvoir enfin
Gabrielle Atal et Marine Le Pen ne sont
pas dans la même situation une est dans
l'opposition là où l'autre est au
pouvoir et l'une monte quand elle agit
peu quand elle se tait quand elle se
cache moins elle en fait mieux elle se
porte Gabriel Atal au contraire
évidemment alors parce qu'il est au
gouvernement et parce que c'est sa
posture politique le mois dernier
pardonnez-moi elle sit pas totalement
cachée Marine Le Pen elle a fait elle a
même elle a même saturé satur et même
les manifester sans se faire her c'est
son talent désormais no peut manifester
en tête de cortège non non c'est vrai
mais il y a une stratégie qui quand même
dans l'opposition consiste à à faire un
minimum de vague là où gabrielalosition
d'extrême droite parce qu'à l'extrême
gauche on fait beaucoup de vaguees oui
oui oui s'agissant de Marine Le Pen
j'imagine qu'on discutera ensuite du
match Mélenchon Le Pen on on parlera de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon un peu plus tard je
voudrais qu'on continue là on a montré
les CIN premiers mais si on descend de
de de deux de deux cran de deux étages
c'est une BR on trouve Mario maréchal
ouais Mar 7e position 27 % de côte de
côte d'adhésion en fait est-ce que ça se
traduit for forcément pardon en en
intention de vote pour les européennes
puisqu les tête de liste aux Européennes
pour le mouvement reconquête d'Éric
Zemour alors pour l'instant en intention
de vote européenne finalement
euh le la liste reconquête est autour
des 7 % ce qui devrait la situer à un
niveau proche de ce qu'elle avait pu
faire précédemment et qui la situe
proche aussi de LR donc ce serait un
score euh plutôt honorable mais euh ce
que j'allais dire sur sur Marion
maréchal Le Pen c'est qu'elle fait
vraiment partie des personnalités qui
comptent à droite mais que son étoile a
quand même P euh en 1 an un an et demi
parce que souvenez-vous en terme de
popularité quand on regardait les
sondages euh elle était très très proche
de sa tante de Marion de de Marine Le
Pen et euh donc un peu de temps avant la
présidentielle elle a même déjà dépassé
Marine Le Pen et il y a tous les
commentaires politiques à un moment
c'était de dire bon allez bientôt le
temps de Marine Le Pen va être terminé
et c'est Marion maréchal qui la
remplacera ce qui fait que son choix
stratégique d'aller chez reconquête
alors voilà c'est un choix qui est aussi
un choix d'adhésion certainement à ce
partilà mais stratégiquement on peut pas
dire que ce soit un franc succès parce
que certes elle est beaucoup plus
populaire qu'Éric Zemour elle est
beaucoup moins rejeté qu'Eric Zemour
maintenant elle est quand même en
seconde division et on parle de Marine
Le Pen donc par donc elle est quand même
Marine Le Pen est à est donc la 3e avec
38 % elle elle est à 27 % en 7e position
donc 11 points derrière et entre deux et
bien il y a Jordan Bardella qui fait un
carton qui plaît beaucoup aux
sympathisant l'extrême droite mais pas
mal aussi aux sympathisants de droite
donc tout ce qu'on disait de Marion
maréchal Le Pen ce rapprochement
possible entre l'extrême droite et la
droite aujourd'hui c'est plus attribué
spontanément à Jordan bellaa qu'à qu'à
Marion maréchal alors je vrais qu'on
parle maintenant de d'Emmanuel Macron
avec un président de la République qui
profite plutôt du contexte international
euh le chef de l'État remercier hier par
certaines familles d'otage français
libéré par le Hamas
écoutez j'aimerais remercier le
président Biden pour le soutien
extraordinaire qu'il a apporté à la
concrétisation de ce
moment ainsi que le président français
Emmanuel Macron et l'ambassade de France
ici en Israël pour leur soutien
extraordinaire
Emmanuel Macron qui voit sa sa code de
popularité est-il un bon Président de la
République c'est la question posée par
notre baromètre réponse non 65 % oui en
légère progression plus un point à 35 %
je me tourne vers i une première fois
dans notre débat peut-être pour un point
général sur ce conflit Israël Hamas
est-ce qu'il pèse toujours autant dans
les conversations sur les réseaux
sociaux ou est-ce que c'est plutôt un
peu en train de se tarir ou de se tasser
alors en effet c'est le conflit en
lui-même ou en tout cas les débats
français issus du conflit ont ont
quelque peu changé de nature on avait vu
sur le dernier baromètre que la la
pénétration était très puissante
l'exportation du débat du conflit était
très puissante dans le pays elle a
tendance à ralentir à affaiblir par
contre très clairement le débat direct
sur le conflit israéli-palestinien s'est
transféré sur la question de
l'antisémitisme qui laisse des traces
politique profonde on évoquait tout à
l'heure la la question de de Marine Le
Pen d'abord le premier point c'est que
les plus gros pic sur sur les réseaux
sociaux ça a été les polémiques autour
de Guillaume Meuris par exemple ou alors
de la marche sur l'antisémitisme contre
l'antisémitisme mais sur ce deuxème
point le vrai sujet qui a mobilisé le le
grand public ce sont les probl les les
polémiques autour des des partis LFI et
RN avec une Marine Le Pen qui a très
clairement engrangé des chiffres qui a
amélioré euh l' so sa propre image qui a
probablement transformé la
perception pivot de l'anti de du Front
national à l'époque qui était considéré
comme le parti antisémite avec une
Marine Le Pen aujourd'hui euh qui euh
passe quasiment dans le C adverse face à
elle Jean-Luc Mélanchon ça a été viendra
plus tard de Jean-Luc Mélenchon je vous
interromps tout de suite faut pas tout
dire dans la dans la première
intervention si vous savez on en
reparlera plus tard de de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon Guillaume meurriis vous avez
fait référence humoriste de France Inter
évidemment qui s'était retrouvé au cœur
d'une polémique pour avoir dans une
chronique traité Benjamin naniaahou de
naz sans prépus pour ceux qui ne
l'auraient pas vu je voudrais qu'on
qu'on justement qu'on discute de de
cette manifestation contre
l'antisémitisme Marine Le Pen y était et
pas Emmanuel Macron Sophie Coignard
est-ce qu'il y a une erreur stratégique
de l'un et une victoire de l'autre bah
sur la sur la victoire enfin oui sur la
réussite de cette séquence par Marine Le
Pen je crois que il y a enfin c'est
difficile de de de le nier ou de le
contester c'est sûr que elle a elle a
engrangé
euh vraisemblablement sur ce sur sur
cette sur cette journée et elle a euh
comment dirais-je elle a engrangé et en
plus elle a enfin elle
a marqué une une comment vous dire un
point de non retour c'est-à-dire que
aujourd'hui et bien effectivement le RN
dans une manifestation contre
l'antisémitisme ça s'est déjà vu et donc
comment vous dire c'est c'est une espèce
de de case qui est coché quoi qu'il en
soit puisque ça s'est pas si mal passé
pour elle c'est pas elle s'est pas pris
des œufs
pourris sur sur elle pendant tout le
pendant pendant tout le défilé euh
Emmanuel Macron c'est très difficile de
trancher à titre personnel je pense
qu'il a commis une erreur euh je pense
qu'il a commis une erreur et et que
cette cette erreur ben peut avoir des
conséquences assez durable non seulement
à cause de son absence mais à cause des
motifs qu'il a donné de cette absence
souvenez-vous quand il a été interpellé
euh par l'arrière petite fille je crois
euh d'Alfred drefus et et et il a dit un
c'est pas dans mes habitudes d'aller
manifester ce qui me paraît un peu en ça
de la strature la stature présidentielle
pour rester très aimable et la deuxième
chose qu'il a dit c'est sinon je
pourrais aller manifester toutes les
semaines et très sincèrement je trouve
que ça lui été très peu reproché par
rapport à ce que ça aurait pu être quand
je l'ai entendu dire ça j'ai vraiment eu
le sentiment qu'il allait le entre
guillemets le payer très cher et
finalement dans le dans le estrom
effectivement des des critiques des uns
et des autres et cetera et des
polémiques s'est passé inaperçu je pense
que à la fois la décision et surtout la
justification n'était pas à la hauteur
de de de la situation d'ailleurs on le
voit dans notre baromètre puisqu'il
progresse même faiblement il progresse à
35 % d'opinion
favorable Mathieu souquier est-ce que
finalement il on a vu effectivement un
président de la République
voilà je fais ce ce terme là sur un sur
une question aussi majeure que le la la
la Renaissance si j'ose dire du conflit
au au proch Orient euh et il le paye pas
politiquement comment vous l'analysez
ouais écoutez c'est pareil il y a pas la
vie est parfois faite de paradoxe et la
vie politique n'est pas fait que de
rationalité c'est vrai que sur
l'international focalisation sur
l'international en général évidemment ça
redor la stature présidentielle ça fait
du bien pour autant comme vous le
rappeliez la séquence a été complexe
pour lui d'abord il y a eu une visite
là-bas qui est venue de façon très
tardive c'estàd que un certain nombre de
chefs d'État ou de chefs de gouvernement
ont précédé ont même largement précédé
Emmanuel Macron au Proche Orient SH
s'est passé avant mais on y est passé
avant enfin donc on avait l'impression
que la France avait un tout petit peu
tardé il avait dit j'irai quand ce sera
utile ouais c'est ça et alors justement
il est allé quand il a jugé que c'était
utile mais en faisant un certain nombre
de propositions qu'à peu près toutes les
chancelleries ont derrière retoqué alors
façon très diplomatique mais quand même
de façon extrêmement claire donc on n'
pas compris qu'il avait à ce moment-là
récupéré le le leadership au plan
international et effectivement la marche
sur le la marche contre l'antisémitisme
il a semblé à front alors à front
renversé après plusieurs jours on avait
compris qu'il tergiversait en plus
c'estàdire que bien souvent on est au
courant du fait que le chef de l'État se
tâte qu'il hésite c'est peut-être oui
peut-être non et à la fin c'est non et
pour le coup précisément comme la
pression était un tout petit peu montée
pendant quelques jours on imaginait
qu'il allait se présenter à la marche en
question et et il n'y était pas
peut-être juste un dernier mot la la la
précédente marche contre l'antisémitisme
30 ans auparavant à l'occasion de la
profanation du Sim juif de carpanra
alors non seulement c'était transformé
en marche contre l'extrême droite
c'estàd que le pays avait manifesté
contre l'antisémitisme mais contre à
l'époque le rassemblement national et
précisément le chef de l'État de
l'époque François mitteran était en tête
de cortège et donc 30 ans après on est à
front rversé ça fait froid dans le dos
c'estàd que le l'extrême droite peut
être là sans se faire caayasser sans se
faire housouspiller sans se faire chuter
c'est aussi mais c'est pas le centre de
de notre débat parce que les ressorts de
l'antisémitisme ont aussi changé dans
notre pays pas en total mais en partie
oui oui absolument et puis on a Éric
Zemour quiil y a pas si longtemps que ça
en fait a incarné la figure du Juif
revendiqué réhabilitant pétant donc tout
ça fait aussi des dégâts considérables
c'est une BR voulez intervenir oui ce
que je veux dire c'est que c'est vrai
que vous suivez la politique de manière
extrêmement fine et épisode par épisode
il faut bien voir que c'est pas le cas
de de la plupart des Français et
c'est-à-dire qu'au moment où arrivent
des événements internationaux
généralement dans les grandes lignes les
Français les suivent et ils connaissent
plutôt quand même bien les grandes
lignes et en l'occurrence ils sont tout
à fait sur les mêmes grandes lignes
qu'Emmanuel Macron c'est-à-dire quand on
les testé à la fois absolument horrifié
parce que par les par les actes du Hamas
et en même temps tout à fait solidaire
des Palestiniens de Gaza et donc
finalement quand on leur pose la
question sur les positions d'Emmanuel
Macron les Français considèrent que ils
sont tout à fait d'accord avec les
positions d'Emmanuel Macron on avait dit
donc Emmanuel Macron a soutenu la
manifestation même s'il n'y a pas
participé et les franç fr disait à la
fois on est content qu'il a soutenu
cette manifestation et on lui en
voudrait pas qu'il n'y participe pas
donc il faut voir quand même que ces
actualité là ça fait plutôt du bien à
une stature présidentielle surtout quand
on soutient les grandes lignes et
qu'après tout le détail les explications
et cetera ça passe quand même au-dessus
de la tête de la plupart des gens ouis
l'actualité politique de ce mardi elle
est encore marquée par les conséquence
du meurtre du jeune Thomas lors de cette
fête de village à Crépol ça a donné lieu
à une passe d'armes à l'Assemblée
nationale aujourd'hui éc Dupont moriti
accusant l'extrême droite
d'instrumentaliser ce drame regardez je
pense aussi moi aux Français à nos
compatriotes aux Français de préférence
qui vivent dans nos quartiers dans les
cités et qui ne méritent pas de lire sur
les murs morts aux Arabes nos frères
juifs ont peur nos Frères musulmans ont
peur aussi vos propos sont incendiaires
et ils amènent dans la rue les militant
de l'ultra drroite qui sont bien plus
proches de vous que de moi pour être
crédible faites le ménage chassez de
vorant les gudards les Identitaires les
nazion les racistes les antisémites qui
sont en réalité planqués dans vos
officines économiques et qui viennent
sévèrement d'être condamné par la cour
d'appel de Paris on a vu les élus du
rassemblé national quitter l'émic tiou
interven et on voit aussi ellisabeth
borne derrière sourire donc elle la
quièe elle sait que éc dupometti peut
faire cette sore là certainement ils en
on discuté avant elle connaît ses
positions et elle la quièe donc il fait
pas cette sortie tout seul ça il faut
bien l'avoir en tête et c'est vrai qu'il
est aussi dans la la logique
rtique depuis toujours été enfin se veut
en première ligne dans le combat contre
le rassemblement national est-ce que
pour autant Sophie coagard là sur ce
point précis c'est la bonne stratégie
c'est un grand débat c'est c'est trop
tôt pour le direop TT pour dire que je
voilà que que l'humilité m'empêche et la
lucidité le fait le fait de pointer ce
qu'il reste ce qu'il reste
d'antisémitisme au sein du rassemblement
national parce que c'est ça sa
stratégous un débat compris enfin c'est
un débat éternel souvenez-vous Fabius
1984 si je ne m'abuse qui dit il est
alors Premier ministre que le Front
national national de l'époque c'était
quand même euh enfin je vaux dire sur
l'antisémitisme il y avait pas vraiment
de doute quoi
euh posait de bonnes questions il
apportait de mauvaises réponses bon ça
c'est ce que disait Laurent Fabius
c'était Fabius 84 ministre Premier
ministre socialiste donc vieille
histoire donc là c'est l'idée que il
faut en gros
que il ne faut pas il ne faut pas
insulter l'avenir et surtout les
éventuels électeurs
du Front national c'était quand même ça
l'idée mais qu'il faut essayer de leur
parler et cetera et puis vous avez la
stratégie qui consiste à dire il faut
dénoncer ce qui'est la réalité de cette
extrême droite désormais certes
encravaté fardé de de républicanisme et
de laïcité et c'est ce qu'a fait
souvenez-vous il y a quelques temps
ellisabeth borne ça
bien complètement d'accord c'est un
débat qui c'est un débat en qui est
cvant même de l'exécutif je suis
totalement d'accord quand Elisabeth
borne a dit en fait ce parti c'est
l'héritier de Pétin et qu'elle s'est
fait recadrer par le président de la ré
donc on voit bien que ce débat n'est pas
tranché et que les tenant de de de la
version j'allais dire
inclusive disent en gros c'est ce qu'a
dit Emmanuel Macron à ellisabeth Borne
écoutez ça fait 30 ans qu'on qu'on
diabolise le Front National et cetera et
on voit le résultat il n'a cessé de
monter la question c'est si on si on
décide de ne pas faire cela mais au
contraire de de le prendre au sérieux
est-ce qu'il ne va pas monter aussi rien
de la démonrer monter encore plus et
finir par briser ce Plon vert qui ferme
les portes de l'É pour l'instant
évidemment ysan si je reviens vers vous
parce que évidemment le le baromètre
doxa n'a pas pu intégrer on va dire le
le le le fait d'hiver qui est devenu
d'ailleurs un fait politique de de
crépole mais est-ce que là si vous avez
regardé ces dernières heures ou ces
derniers jours à quel point ça prend de
la place justement et sous quelle forme
surtout euh sur les médias sociaux tout
à fait je vais m'en tenir au au fait
mais on a un ratio de ce qu'on appelle
les engagements qui est très important
sur les les les les 30 derniers jours on
va dire c'est euh ça représente 1,7
millions de mentions c'est vraiment très
important sur les réseaux sociaux mais
sur les faits on va quand même noter
quelque chose de particulier c'est que
d'abord le phénomène d'extrême droite
l'agitation extrême droite sur les
réseaux sociaux elle est réelle euh
c'est c'est-à-dire Queau sein des
résultats les plus importants qu'on a on
retrouve principalement les noms des
chantres de l'extrême droite Marion
maréchal Damien Rieux juliaen oudoule et
cetera beaucoup
d'influenceurs très connus des réseaux
bin Français de souche livre noir et
cetera le deuxième point c'est la
présence très forte qui est un peu
troublante de compte étrangers
principalement américains qui sont
affiliés à des tendances radicales de
droite et qui sont parmi les contenus
les plus partagés avec il y a un symbole
qui existe qui est celui de la déchéance
de la France et il est lié à à crépul et
enfin il y a un débat très clairement
sur le champ sémantique un lexiteque
très chargé parfois violent vous le
savez les racailles les barbares les
sauvages qu'on retrouve dans certaines
enceintes et qui est associé au fameux
vivement le 9 juin qui est qui a été
lancé par Marine Le Pen donc il y a une
vraie activation d'une stratégie des
réseaux d'extrême droite avec aussi une
contestation du du mon Rix alors qui ne
préjuge pas de
la de de de l'importance du phénomène
qui reste qui est devenu un phénomène
politique mais aussi un un fait de
société c'est vrai mais l'activation de
l'extrême droite est très très forte et
elle est vue en tant que telle par
beaucoup d'internautes sur les réseaux
sociaux merci beaucoup y San 9 juin
évidemment les élections EUR Mathieu
souquier c'est c'est assez passionnant
ce que vient de nous dire ifsan
notamment sur le les les les les comptes
qui viennent de d'autres pays là des
États-Unis qui finalement active la
machine médiatique aussi autour d'un
fait d'hiver comme comme celui-là
comment vous l'analyz et est-ce qu'on
est peut-être un peu trop tôt pour le
dire là aussi mais dans une stratégie à
6 mois quoi ou à voilà si on se projette
dans le cadre des européne il y a eu
aussi ce qui s'est passé à Dublin par
exemple voilà une attaque au couteau des
manifestations d'extrême droite dans les
très violentes dans les jours qui ont
qui ont suivi alors il y a il y a une
Internationale des nationalistes qui se
constitue effectivement et c'est la
magie des réseaux sociaux ça permet
précisément de faire ce
qu'historiquement les nationalistes
n'ont pas réussi à faire alors dans
l'histoire de l'extrême droite il y a
toujours eu une instrumentalisation
d'effets divers ça ça a existé
précisément à toutes les époques en tout
cas depuis que l'extrême droite existe
et à l'époque de Jean-Marie Le Pen
c'était papivoise en pleine campagne
présidentielle il y a toujours eu ça
puisque derrière encore une fois la
stratégie du du rassemblement national
enfin de exême droite dans son ensemble
c'est de c'est d'arriver à consolider
une vision de la société ensuvagée une
société violente de plus en plus VI très
violente de plus en plus violente donc
de se poser évidemment comme rempart de
cette violence et deuxième dimension de
d'accréditer l'idée que cette violence
ou cette montée de la violence qui n'est
pas toujours documenté mais que cette
montée de la violence précisément serait
directement lié au fait migratoire et
puis du fait migratoire il y a il y a
les migrants il y a ceux qui arrivent
aujourd'hui puis il y a tous ceux qui
sont arrivés dans le passé mais qu'on
finit par associer à ceux qui sont les
nouveaux arrivants donc voilà donc cette
stratégie en fait elle est très ancienne
elle est elle est en tout cas
aujourd'hui très efficace et ça reboucle
avec ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure
la stratégie la plus efficace face à
l'extrême droite personne ne l'a trouvé
c'estàdire que le combat moral le combat
sur les valeurs ça fait effectivement 40
ou 50 ans qu'on le mène ça n'empêche pas
l'extrême droite de prospérer de ce
point de vue-là il y a pas seulement en
fait des des désaccords au sein du
gouvernement ou à la tête de l'État il y
a même une forme d'incohérence enfin je
veux dire on a du pont Moretti qui dit
ce qu'il dit aujourd'hui mais il y a
quelques mois il y avait Géral Dar qui
reprochait à Marine à Marine Le Pen sa
molesse qui instruisait le procès en
Mola deimessionession que là ça a encore
changé parce qu'avec le déplacement
d'Olivier verrand à crpul avec ce qu'il
a dit aussi il va plusutôt dans le sens
de l'opinion publique au ouais donc on
on on y comprend plus rien et deuxième
dimension le combat sur les valeurs
effectivement il est sans efficacité le
combat sur les résultats c'est l'idée
que il suffirait de faire reculer le
chômage pour faire reculer l'extrême
droite on sait que c'est pas le cas
depuis lonel Jospin et on a confirmation
avec avec Emmanuel Macron que ça ne
marche pas davantage allez une autre
leçon notre baromètre odoxa mascaré pour
Public Sénat et les titres de la PQR les
difficultés d'éliisabeth borne
popularité qui est stable 30 % d'opinion
favorable on peut voir ce premier ce
premier élémen 69 % d'opinion
défavorable euh et puis il y a une autre
question Elisabeth borne doit-elle
rester première ministre et là le nom
l'emporte à 61 % laetia ça se double
d'un d'un retour des R eur sur le
remanement c'est de nouveau auudessus de
la tête d'Élisabeth borne apparemment
oui Thomas seulement 4 mois après que
Emmanuel Macron les maintenu c'était en
juillet hein dans son poste de première
ministre après la réforme mouvementée
des retraites elle aurait pu sauter à ce
moment-là Emmanuel Macron a décidé de la
garder et bien ça revient ces rumeurs et
toujours la même question borne
peut-elle tenir alors avant c'était
après la réforme de sur la retraite et
maintenant ce sera après la loi
immigration qui est discuté en ce moment
au Parlement et aussi dans la
perspective des élections européennes
elle av refusé he elle voulait pas y
aller elle voulait pas être tête de
liste pourquoi parce qu'elle ne voulait
pas se retrouver sur un siège
éjectable en cas de grande victoire du
RN et là elle s'y retrouve quand même
Thomas pourquoi parce que dans tous les
sondages apparemment euh les macronistes
c'est ce qui se murmure hein aurait
quelques sueur froide et dirait que le
RN pour l'instant pas par grand gagnant
et que si c'est le cas en juin cela
marquerait il y en a qui vont fort
carrément la fin du dernier quinquena
d'Emmanuel Macron et ce serait la faute
d'Élisabeth borne est-ce que vous avez
trouvé le même son de cloche du côté de
l'Élysée ce n'est pas si évident du côté
de l'Élysée pour le moment le président
serait ce qu'on me dit en mode réflexion
et il srait à Touva pour savoir s'il
faut remanier ou pas parce que
figurez-vous Thomas que il pourrait y
avoir uniquement un remanimement
ministériel notamment après les procès
du pont Moretti et du sopt en fonction
de comment ça se passe en gardant
ellisabeth borne donc il y aurait ça
c'est un mot qu'Emmanuel Macron aime des
ajustements voilà et la première
ministre qui qui a prévu forcément enfin
on lesesper Poel une stratégie de
défense oui elle parle peu éisabeth
borne elle a dit la semaine dernière à
la presse à propos de ces rumeurs de
remanimement ça fait 10 fois que
j'entends ça c'est vrai mais ça
l'empêche pas d'agir elle agit elle agit
là dernièrement elle multiplie les
déplacements si vous êtes attentif vous
pouvez le remarquer et aussi les prises
de position fortes hier par exemple elle
a carrément rejeté le compromis sur la
l'assurance chômage à la barbe des
syndicats qui était furieux et du
patronat aussi d'ailleurs et du patronat
oui
notamment bon elle demandait des
garanties sur les économies faites sur
lesocations des des seniors mais enfin
elle a marqué en tout cas ça voilà elle
a posé sa marque et dans la majorité
elle prend les choses en mains et ça
commence dès ce soir dès ce soir elle
reçoit les parlementaires ça va être C
dîners cinq réunions de travail on dit
plutôt à Matignon où elle reçoit les
parlementaires de la majorité pourquoi
pour lancer le premier semestre de
réforme dès janvier 2024 donc borne
c'est très simple le message qu'elle
envoie montre qu'elle est à sa tâche
allez une conclusion pourquoi elle est
de nouveau fragilisé écoutez on l'a vu
dans le sujet d'introduction et c'est
vrai que quand sat tangue c'est comme ça
le Premier ministre est infusible donc
elle est infusible en ce moment ça t
depuis la réforme sur les retraites et
il y a deux problèmes pour ellisabeth
Bourne en terme d'image déjà elle est
masquée presque même invisible à cause
d'doir Philippe et de cette popularité
qui reste très stable la pauvre
ellisabeth borne tente de subsister mais
dans les sondage on voit qu'elle est
carrément invisibilisée et aussi autre a
re problème d'image quand même elle est
la madame 493 multiplié sur les textes
budgétaires or quand on sonde les
Français vous êtes bien placés pour le
savoir le 493 cette mesure est jugée par
une grande partie de la population comme
un dénis de démocratie donc c'est
largement impopulaire et cette
impopularité lui colle à la peau merci
Laeticia quelques mots rapides sur
Elisabeth band il y a un côté supplice
chinois quand même Sophie Coignard je
sais bien que le le c'est le lot de tous
les premierers ministres d'être sur un
siège éject mais là c'est j'ai
l'impression
ça ça revient tous les deux TR mois quoi
il y a un raffinement particulier euh
alors on voit bien que ellisabeth borne
elle est à la
fois comment dirais-je c'est une dure à
cuire et en même temps elle elle en elle
en a assez enfin je veux
dire aussi je déclenche l'article 493 en
fait c'est une phrase qu'elle peut plus
supporter euh S souvenons-nous quand
même puisqu'on parlait d'Édouard
Philippe qu'Édouard Philippe
effectivement une des raisons pour
lesquelles on l'a remercié de matigon
c'était qu'il était plus populaire que
le président alors si je puis
dire Elisabeth bord ne court pas ce
risque là donc essayons de voilà
essayons de positiver pour elle c'est
pour ça qu'emuel Macron va peut-être la
garder en remagant et d'une certaine
manière les les enfin Emmanuel Macron a
a déjeuné récemment avec Nicolas Sar
euh Nicolas Sarkozi son son idée a
plutôt été d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'il a
fait d'user un premier ministre jusqu'à
la corde et et ellisabeth
borne peut encore servir il y a quand
même des gens dans la majorité qui qui
disent justement à cause de cette
échéance des européennes que ce serait
complexe de griller la cartouche du
changement de Premier ministre avant les
élections de juin parce que si jamais
c'est effectivement une catastrophe pour
la
majorité faudra encore changer peut-être
de Premier ministre effectivement qui
serait le meilleur pour remplacer on se
projette he la plupart du temps
d'ailleurs ça se passe comme ça c'est
lié aux élections quand mêmeid
évidemment vous avez sondé aussi
l'opinion sur le le le le meilleur
remplaçant enfin le meilleur successeur
pour être précis qui serait le meilleur
premier ministre voilà je vais pas faire
c'est pas un grand scoop c'est la la
comète du moment c'est Gabriel àal qui
est cité en premier voyez à 30 % devant
Bruno Leem 27 % loin devant Gérald
d'armanin qui est le le malaimé de
l'opinion et devant Julien de Normandie
et Sébastien lecnu qui tous deux
souffrent d'un d'un gros déficit de
notoriété en réalité avant de de parler
d'impopularité de de ces deux-là pour
Gabriel Attal et Bruno LEM ils sont un
peu dans un mouchoir de poche en réalité
avec des soutiens assez différents
c'est-à-dire que par exemple Gabriel
hatal est quelqu'un qui est très
apprécié y compris à droite y compris
par les sympathisants de LR sur sa côte
il est même audessus de Bruno Le Maire
mais vous voyez quand on pose la
question qui vous préférez comme premier
ministre là les sympathisants de droit
disent Bruno Le Maire de même que
d'ailleurs les sympathisants de
Renaissance comme s'il y avait une
espèce de quand même de gage à la
maturité la stature l'expérience
politique on dit non là quand même quand
même Bruno Lemire mais on voit quand
même que Gabriel Atal progresse de
manière spectaculaire sur notre
baromètre en popularité en en terme dans
dans l'opinion de manière détaillée il
est considéré comme un bon ministre de
l'Éducation toutes les les pistes de
réforme qu'il a proposé sont vraiment
acclamé par l'opinion et puis en plus
vous n parlez de Gabriel on voit Bruno
le derrière vous mais c'est bien
gabriqu moi je le vois devant moi j'ai
l'impression que je parle de lui et
voilà donc donc vraiment là en voilà en
tant que Premier ministre ça pourrait en
effet avoir du sens sans doute politique
aussi de pouvoir mettre quelqu'un qui
soit jeune et qui soit soit considéré
comme quelqu'un bah de courageux de
compétent et et de fidèle ce qui peut
servir allez il nous reste allez un peu
plus de 5 minutes comme promis on va
parler de Jean-Luc Mélenchon je propose
à Quentin calm de de de nous rejoindre
on va voir s'afficher l'un des
enseignements de la l'étudodoxa bonsoir
Quentin avec la code de confiance de
Jean-Luc mélanchot côe de confiance qui
est à seulement 18 % euh bon c'est une
chute constante c'est çaou c'est même
une nette baisse depuis juin dernier
Thomas Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui est passé
de la 6e place des politiques dans leur
code de confiance à la 17e il devient
même à l'inverse l'une des personnalités
les plus clivantes ce qui qui provoque
le plus de rejet à 60 % des Français
interrogé c'est juste derrière erriic
Zemour qui est à 62 %. pour autant
Jean-Luc Mélenchon reste la personnalité
la plus envue à gauche absolument mais
attention là encore ça baisse mais à 44
% d'adhésion il a perdu de points en un
mois et c'est 12 points depuis le mois
de juin selon l'étude il rejoint un
groupe de personnalités auut tout de 40
% d'adhésion à gauche dont Fabien
Roussell Édouard Philippe et François
Ruffin l'étude note pourtant que
Jean-Luc Mélenchon devançait de 15
points toutes ses personnalités avant
l'été et donc si on rentre dans le
détail il est jugé trop radical voilà
pour expliquer les mauvais chiffres
depuis juin dernier effectivement le
point de départ c'est la stratégie
d'obstruction à l'Assemblée nationale
pendant la période de la réforme des
retraites mais les critiques sont de
plus en plus vives depuis les massacres
du Hamas du 7 octobre exemple avec ce
tweet du 22 octobre où le fondateur de
la France insoumise s'en prend à yel
Bron Pivet la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale qui campe à TelAviv la ligne
Mélenchon est contestée en interne et
c'est nouveau et ce de plus en plus
ouvertement le 12 novembre dernier on
voit ainsi plusieurs élus insoumis
manifester contre l'antisémitisme
n'hésitons pas à se démarquer de la
position de et bien des cadres du parti
on voit ainsi François Ruffin Raquel g
Alexis corb et clémentinetin défilé à
Strasbourg et mi-nvembre c'est la
députée Raquel garido qui est sanctionné
par le groupe Alfi de l'Assemblée
nationale pour ses prises de position
qui nuisent je cite au bon
fonctionnement collectif du groupe en
clair la direction du groupe Alfi lui
reproche d'avoir critiqué Jean-Luc
Mélenchon et même de l'avoir revendiqué
dans le journal LOPS un conflit s'ouvre
entre la députée et la direction de LFI
écoutez Raquel garido c'était
mi-novembre sur notre
antenne il y a un problme à la direction
de la France insoumise il y a besoin
d'avoir à à mon sens un sursaut là un
sursaut
éthique j'ai l'impression que leur
boussole je sais pas c'est c'est c'est
déboussolé voilà elle elle ne marche
plus donc il y a besoin que les insoumis
voilà se se ressaisissent fasse du
commun dans l'unité des élus insoumis
qui sont peu nombreux à s'en prendre
directement à jeanl voilà tout se fait à
fleur et moucheté effectivement même un
député comme François Ruffin qui joue
pourtant sa propre partition depuis
plusieurs semaines et bien il propose
une alternative à gauche mais sans
jamais se mettre vraiment à dos son
ancien chef de file écoutez c'était
dimanche dernier sur France 3 est-ce que
pour vous Jean-Luc Mélenchon reste une
référence comment ne serait pas une
référence l'homme qui a permis de sauver
la gauche dans le pays il faut bien voir
que si la gauche ça avait été François
Hollande et son fils adoptif Emmanuel
Macron la gauche elle serait morte et
enterrée aujourd'hui donc il a sa place
dans votre nouveau mouvement bah le
mouvement il est plus large que ça la
mouvement c'est la gauche en
général que Jean-Luc Mélanchon a sa
place dans dans dans dans le panthéon de
la gauche ouis le pantthéon de la gauche
mais ça veut dire un peu un peu dans
notre passé hein on est bien compris
dans la bouche de de François rifin
absolument mais donc on l'entend pour
l'heure il s'agit pour lui plutôt de de
poser d'autres carte sur la table à
gauche sans jamais lancer de conflet
ouvert on l'a compris avec Jean-Luc mé
merci beaucoup Quentin Mathieu sou je me
tourne vers vous parce que faire émerger
une alternative à Jean-Luc Mélenchon
àfi est-ce possible sans quitter LFI
vous voyez ce que je veux dire alors
sans quitter LFI ça paraît compliqué et
même je dirais qu'en quittant LFI ça va
ça va l'être en réalité la question
posée la question sous-jacente est celle
effectivement de la posture politique et
de la stratégie politique Jean-Luc
Mélenchon fait évidemment tout ce qu'il
fait de façon totalement construite
totalement pensée il fait le Paris que
clivé aujourd'hui politiquement et y
compris aller dans l'outrance dans
l'excès et dans la violence c'est pas
seulement la radicalité mais dans la
violence ça vocation à payer à terme
alors ce qui est sûr c'est que à ce
stade dans les enquêtes d'opinion Marine
Le Pen par une posture radicalement
opposée à plier le match des opposants
ça c'est incontestable en terme de
proximité de danger de compét de tout ça
en fait Jean-Luc Mélenchon est à ce
stade à ce stade en tout cas distancé
alors il avait connu une vraie chute
après la dernière présidentielle et puis
il avait l'avantnière présid et puis il
avait réussi à remonter jusqu'à un score
tout à fait inédit en en 2022 et donc on
voit bien que il se dit que en réalité
il peut y avoir des creux de vagu et que
les creux de vagues ne sont jamais
définitifs c'est c'est un Paris ce qui
est sûr c'est que aujourd'hui alors que
l'opinion de gauche était unitaire à 80
% il y a un an encore elle ne l'est plus
majoritairement aujourd'hui 80 % des
sympathisants de gauche disaient il y a
un an nous devons faire l'unité et il
n'y a pas de gauche irréconciliable ce
qui nous rapproche dépasse ce qui nous
divise aujourd'hui en revanche à partir
de de précisément en fait de la posture
du du leader insoumis ce ne sont plus
que 46 % des sympathisants de gauche qui
se disent unitair donc la nupess a pris
cher quand même merci beaucoup merci à
tous d'avoir participé à ce débat sur
Public Sénat je vous dis à très bientôt
j'ouvre notre second débat il porte sur
une réforme que le Président de la
République hésite à mettre en place
celle de l'euthanasie après avoir lancé
le débat national sur la fin de vie
Emmanuel Macron avait promis un texte
pour la fin de l'été il se fait toujours
attendre avant d'expliquer ses
hésitations voir ce qui pourrait ce que
pourrait contenir une nouvelle loi on va
détailler déjà le cadre juridique
existant la loi Clais Leonetti avec
famia REER c'était une promesse
d'Emmanuel Macron faire avancer en
France le droit à mourir dans la dignité
une cause qui doit trouver comme je l'ai
promis une traduction dans une loi de
liberté et de respect il existe pourtant
déjà un texte qui encadre la fin de vie
voté en 2016 la loi clè Leonetti
renforce les droits des malades contre
l'acharnement thérapeutique mais à
certaines conditions quand la maladie
est incurable que le pronostic vital est
engagé à court terme et que les
souffrances sont réfractaires à tout
traitement dans ce cas précis la loi
autorise de mettre le patient dans le
coma et d'arrêter ses traitement dont
l'alimentation jusqu'au décès ce cadre
là ça justifie d'arrêter des trait qui
sont administrés au patient et qui
maintiennent la vie du patient de façon
artificielle on va arrêter des
thérapeutiqu qui sont déraisonnables et
qui maintiennent la vie
artificiellement pour probablement pas
de bénéfice derrière mais la loi ne
répond pas aujourd'hui à toutes les
situations par exemple quand la maladie
est incurable et que les souffrances ne
peuvent être traités mais que le
pronostic vital du patient n'est pas
engagé à court terme parle pas d'une fin
de vie dans les jours qui suivent mais
d'une fin de vie dans les mois voire
années qui suivent et là dans ce cadre-
là on n' pas aujourd'hui en France une
loi qui permet finalement de raccourcir
cette période et d'accéder à une fin de
vie au moment où où le patient le
souhaite la nouvelle loi devrait
apporter une réponse à ces patients sans
solution pour éviter le recours à une
euthanasie à l'étranger comme en
Belgique ou en Suisse voire à une
euthanasie clandestine
faut-il autoriser une exception
d'euthanasie on en débat avec Corine
Ambert bonsoir vous êtes sénatrice
àarentlr de la Charente Maritime et
co-auteur du rapport fin de vie
privilégié une éthique du soin rapport
sénatorial évidemment Denis label
bonsoir et bienvenue ancien chef de
service des hôpitaux de Paris
co-président de l'association le choix
et auteur de ce livre le médecin la
liberté et la mort aux éditions plomb
Valérie de pad bonsoir et bienvenue vous
êtes maître de conférence en droit privé
à l'université Sorbonne Paris Nord
ancienne membre de la commission SICAR
de réflexion sur la fin de vie euh en
France évidemment laéticia crupa est
restée euh euh à mes côtés Corine Ambert
dans dans votre rapport euh vous
proposez de renforcer la loi Clais
Leonetti euh vers une sans aller vers
une aide active à mourir pourquoi ce
choix parce que euh parce que une
évolution législative nous paraît euh
euh d'abord euh répondre à une commande
présidentielle HM pas forcément euh euh
et puis parce que nous avons considéré à
travers les auditions que nous avons
mené conjointement avec deux de mes
collègues euh que la loi cllonetti avait
quand même été un grand pas euh vers une
un apaisement de la fin de vie et
qu'elle c'était presque un même si elle
est mal connue et mal appliquée elle a
été votée rappelons-le en 2016 il y a
voilà il y a un peu plus de 7 ans euh et
on peut tous regretter qu'elle soit mal
connue et mal appliquée mais que ça
reste quand même une chance pour notre
euh outil législatif d'avoir cette loi
et nous préférions améliorer la loi que
de s'engager en tout cas dans dans le
rapport tel que nous l'avons rédigé vous
avez vu que ce rapport nous l'avons fait
à trois à trois nous étions trois
sénatrice et qu' avait un avis divergent
qui est exprimé dans le rapport mais
qu'à notre niveau nous onons préféré
préféré parler d'une
éthique du soin d'une d'une fin de vie
apaisé grâce à cette loi là parce
qu'elle répond quand même à énormément
énormément de situations et on a
toujours mis en exemple une maladie la
maladie de Charkos qui est assez
stigmatisant aussi pour les patients
comme étant une raison nécessaire et
suffisante pour faire évoluer la loi
dans notre pays voilà donc c'était la
position de que nous avons prise donc
pas de légalisation l'ethanasie on l' on
l' on l'a bien compris on pourra
détailler et en reparler évidemment ce
débat du du Tro quart d'heure que dit le
serment d'Hippocrate que font tous les
médecins le jour où ils sont diplômés je
ferai tout pour s les souffrances je ne
prolongerai pas abusivement les agonies
je ne provoquerai jamais la mort
délibérément Denis labelle est-ce qu'il
faut changer ce ce serment et surtout
changer la loi pour permettre le al
commer par le serment le serment il y a
pas un serment il y a plusieurs serments
parce que Hippocrate c'était longtemps
son texte a complètement évolué
aujourd'hui c'est le serment du conseil
de l'ordre des médecins puis le dernière
version c'est 2012 c'est marqué comme ça
sur internet avec une correction en 2020
qui est un peu différente alors bien sûr
il y a marqué cela dans le serment
d'Hippocrate mais il est marqué plein
d'autres choses que les gens oublient il
marqué je respecterai la volonté de mon
malade ouis je ne prolongerai pas
l'agonie inutilement or dans la loi
classit on prolonge l'agonie inutilement
ce qu'on oublie de dire c'est un point
très très important ensuite je
soulagerai les souffrances al moi jeais
savoir comment on peut traiter l'agonie
réduire l'agonie sans augmenter les
doses de sédatif et de morphinique là il
y a une incompatibilité bien sûr qu'on
aide les malades à mourir quand on fait
de la sédation efficace donc il y a une
forme d'hypocrisie totale et totale et
là vous avez tout à fait raison c'est
qu'elle est mal connue parce que la
plupart des politiques n'ont pas lu le
texte d'application de la Haute Autorité
de Santé de
2018 qui dit que en effet vous allez
déshydrater l'individu vous allez avoir
une sédation fluctuante c'està-dire
d'abord on l'endort puis ensuite sil se
réveille et ben on lui refait une dose
mais encore faut-il être là pour lui
refaire la dose il est prévu que le
médecin doit passer deux fois par jour
quand il s'est en ville et trois fois en
épade voyez le samedi le dimanche le
médecin passé trois fois en épad c'est
ça la loi actuelle donc c'est pour ça
qu'il faut la changer mais bien sûr
c'est absolument inacceptable ce
protocole estacceptable et puis en plus
elle ne répond pas à des indications
fondamentales les maladies
neurodégénératives c'est pas seulement
la maladie Charco c'est beaucoup
d'autres maladie et des gens qui ont des
cancers qui sont à un stade avancé mais
qui n'est pas terminal vous avez demain
un cancer du pancréas qui est évolué qui
est avancé mais vous êtes pas dans une
situation
prémortème il y a des gens qui disent ça
suffit j'ai pas envie de
il faut les entendre alors qu'avec la
loi aujourd'hui il faut quoi il faut
être à quelques quelques jours il
fautêtre quelques heures c'est marqué
voilà et les gens partent à l'étranger
justement pour trouver la solution qu'on
leur offre pas Valérie je l'ai dit en
titre on parle d'exception d'euthanasie
on en parle alors est-ce que c'est c'est
c'est un terme juridique c'est de quoi
il s'agit ou on s'est aperçu enfin je
beaucoup beaucoup de rapport
l'expliquent quand tu soins palliatifs
de qualité HM temps qu'il faut propos à
Lane et qu' les accepte bien souvent la
demande s'arrête mais pas dans tous les
cas et c'est pour ça qu'on dit puisque
le maintien de la demande est
exceptionnel pourquoi ne pas créer une
exception alors là le problème est
juridique parce qu'une exception à quoi
on a pas un grand texte qui nous
interdit l'ethanasie ou l'assistance au
suicide et auquel on ferait exception si
on fait exception ce sera à à des
notions beaucoup plus générales comme
l'assassinat l'empoisonnement qui
s'accorde quand même très mal de la
question ne serait-ce que l'élément
intentionnel enfin ce sont des ce sont
des ce sont des crimes ce sont des voilà
on est dans le pénal c'est pas c'est pas
du tout adapté sans prendre parti sur le
le le fond parce que c'est pas votre
votre rôle mais cette loi est-ce qu'elle
a quand même besoin d'être toilettée
même si elle est relativement récente
alors est-ce qu'elle manque de précision
par exemple est-ce qu'on peut dire ça
bah de précision ça c'est les médecins
qu' savent au moment de l'application je
pense que cette loi est appliquée de
façon très différente d'un d'une équipe
à une autre h euh je sais pour avoir
travaillé avec des réanimateurs qu'il
n'aiment pas cette procédure parce qu'il
s'interroge sur ce que vit la personne
pendant ce temps de sommeil à quoi rime
ce temps de de sommeil enfin de de
sédation qui peut se prolonger qui se
peut se prolonger on saura jamais
puisquelle en revient pas exactement ce
ce que vit la personne et puis il y a
quand même un angle mort c'est ce que
disait le docteur là et sans sans
décider parce que je pense que c'est une
question sociétale qui revient au par
c'est vrai qu'il y a des personnes qui
ne veulent plus vivre qui veulent que
leur vie s'arrête leur pronostic vital
est engagé on a aucune thérapeutique à
leur proposer je crois que la première
chose à proposer c'est la vie avec des
soins palliatifs de qualité mais s'ils
échouent il va bien falloir poser la
question à nos représentants ouis Corine
est-ce que c'est c'est ces cas dont on
parle justifient vous nous dites c'est
finalement ce que j'ai compris de votre
première intervention quand vous dites
ça concerne surtout la maladie de
charcoot bon on va pas faire ça pour une
seule maladie alors c'est pas ce que
j'ai dit j'ai dit que c'était c'était
celle qui était mis en avant C celle qui
était mise en avant systématiquement
alors qu'effectivement ce que disait le
professeur il y a d'autres pathologies
euh et donc s'il y a beaucoup de
pathologies qui sont potentiellement
concerné pourquoi ne pas changer la loi
d'après vous hein parce que je trouve
que faire évoluer la loi alors encore
une fois la discussion n'a pas lieu au
Parlement pour l'instant on a fait une
mission d'information conduite avec par
trois sénatrices euh et et même si à
l'occasion d'une proposition de loi il y
a quelques
mois nous avions eu ce débat ici au
Sénat et c'est à l'issue de cette ce
cette proposition de loi que j'avais
demandé déjà à conduire une mission
d'information sur les soins palliatifs
et l'état des soins palliatifs dans
notre pays je rappellerai qu'on en est
au 5e plan et qu'on voit bien qu'il y a
des grosses inégalités territoriales on
on va détailler le mais c'est important
parce que moi je pense que on on irait
peut-être un peu vite en besogne même si
effectivement il y aura toujours des
situations difficiles difficiles à vivre
pour les patients d'abord pour leur
famille qui justifieraient peut-être une
évolution législative je dis bien
peut-être tant qu'on a'ura pas à un
moment donné permis l'accès au soins
palgatif à tous les patients hm je je
pense que premièrement il est là parce
que c'est pas acceptable aujourd'hui
quand alors qu'on est au 5e plan même si
je sais que c'est beaucoup d'argent mais
si qu'on puisse avoir autant de décalage
dans tous les territoires et que les
patients n passent parce que quand ils
rentrent dans une unité de soin
palliatif la demande de mourir elle
diminue fortement voir elle disparaît
ouais je je voudrais qu'on reste sur
cette cette notion de de choix
finalement un patient peut-il choisir sa
mort c'est vraiment la question centrale
évidemment de ce de ce débat je vous
propose un témoignage
elle s'appelle Sylvie Richard on est en
juin 2018 c'est une patiente qui est
âgée de 67 ans à l'époque elle est
atteinte d'un cancer incurable elle
vient d'apprendre que sa demande
d'euthanasie a été acceptée en Belgique
on l'écoute ma mort m'appartient et que
je laisserait personne me laa voler
parce que pour moi c'est ça on me
volerait ma propre mort et ça je me'y
refuse de toutes mes forces tous ces
épidodes de ma vie font que voilà j'ai
toujours dit que le jour où je serai
atteinte d'une maladie grave je ferai je
veux partir dignement Denis Lab est-ce
que la loi dans sa dans dans sa forme
actuelle prend suffisamment en compte
justement le le choix du patient non qui
a le pouvoir presque la question elle
est un peu mais c'est çao non c'est le
problème essentiel quand la maladie
devient incurable moi je pense que le
médecin doit rester là il doit continuer
à accompagner son patient et jusqu'à la
fin c'est son rôle pour moi mais les les
cartes ont changé la maladie est
incurable le malade doit reprendre en
main sa destinée ça me semble
fondamental c'est son c'est sa vie c'est
sa dernière liberté c'est une liberté
qui n'empi en rien sur les libertés des
autres ça me semble absolument essentiel
et puis a une chose très importante
c'est qu'il y a pas seulement des gens
qui souhaitent l'aide médicale à mourir
il y a tous ceux qui ne l'fferont pas
mais la loi modifie leur mentalité h en
Belgique par exemple vous n'avez que 2,5
% des gens qui demandent l'aide médicale
à mourir c'est pas important 4
% en Hollande on arrive à 5 % au Québec
mais quand vous faites des enquêtes
sociologiques 80 % des Belges ne veulent
pas qu'on revienne en arrière parce que
cette loi désangoisse elle existe depuis
20 ans hein elle désangoisse
c'est-à-dire que même si je l'utilise
pas le fait même de savoir
qu'éventuellement quelle que soit la
situation je pourrais éventuellement
l'utiliser ça modifie complètement et ça
c'est essentiel encore faut-il Valérie
de avoir dit ce qu'on souhaitait faire
euh et là j'ai l'impression qu'on est un
peu on un peu en retard là-dessus aussi
il y a des préalables le premier vous en
parliez je crois qu'on y reviendra c'est
de proposer la vie avec des soins
palliatif piatif ouais et de savoir ce
que veut la personne si elle se trouve à
un moment dans un état de de vigilance
altérée ça dure ça dure
bon je pense qu'on ne touchera jamais
qu'on mettra jamais fin de façon
anticipée à la vie d'une personne qui
naura pas exprimer sa volonté et pour
l'instant les directives anticipées
c'est plutôt un échec quand même chez
nous pour des raisons culturell quoi de
campagne d'informationformation et puis
je pense et je le comprends tout à fait
qu'on n pas envie de de penser à à sa
propre mort c'est pour ça que je pense
que il faut faire rentrer dans la
culture parce qu'on en a besoin et le
faire rentrer dans la culture je pense
qu'il faut s'adresser aux jeun
par exemple lors de la journée civique
lorsque la mort paraît loin lorsqu'on a
la force de la jeunesse on s'exprime
plus facilement en en expliquant bien à
l'ensemble des jeunes qu'évidemment ils
vont sûrement évoluer dans leurs pensées
et qu'ils pourront revenir à tout moment
sur ces directives mais le commencer
jeune commencer à poser la question aux
personnes jeunes plus on moi on a envie
de remp les direc anticiper enfin bon
c'est c'est aussi clair que ça he je
pense
ou quand tant qu'on est jeune ça paraît
tellement loin ça parait oui mais alors
si on remplit ça à 25 ans on a le droit
changer la vie voilà c'est ça on ait de
changer VIP modifiable jusqu'à leur
application ou ça il faudra bien le dire
quand même
évidemment corinebert sur le finalement
ça rejoint un peu la question de le de
l'opinion publique des Français les
Français sont-ils prêts à à accepter
l'euthanasie moi je répondrait oui si
l'on en croit les sondages qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez
oui si l'on en croit les S
ce qui suit c'est est-ce qu'on doit
légiférer selon les sondages c'est un
sujet il y a un tabou de la fin de vie
il y a un dénis de la mort il y a même
un dénis de la mort dans la formation
des médecins sur ferror de ma part qu'on
en parle peu c'est quelque chose qu'on
on a mis de côté avant la mort elle se
vivait en famille
euh ça c'est un premier sujet
effectivement ceux qui répondent au
sondage je dis pas qu'il y a pas de gens
malades on est tous des malades
potentiels hein mais la la la position
la réponse au sondage est pas forcément
la même quand vous êtes bien portant
quand vous êtes vieillissant d'une
maladie incurable et d'un autre côté ça
vient on atint presque ne9 Français sur
10 he le dernier sondage on a cherché ça
cet après-midi c'est quand même oui oui
mais je conteste pas
le je conteste pas les les les les
sondage je je j'essaie juste de de de de
prendre un petit peu de de de de recul
et puis pour me dire bah voilà si demain
je dois je dois examiner ce texte voter
et cetera voilà
écur la
responsabilitéilé par j'entendais que
effectivement dans une
démocratie normale j'allais dire entre
guillemets j'aime j'aime pas le terme
mais effectivement on obligera personne
à choisir l'adactif à murir si le
patient n'a pas envie évidemment est-ce
que ça pourrait faire l'objet d'un
référendum je ne sais pas je sais pas si
le président de la République en a envie
p pense que s'il tarde à sortir le texte
et et à donner le feu vert au texte
c'est peut-être parce qu'il a peut-être
peur de ce que votera le Parlement et
que ça ira au-delà de ce qu' peut
imaginer on on y reviendra sur les sur
les hésitations d'Emmanuel Macron je
vrais qu'on parle des pardon je je vrais
qu'on parle des soins palliatifs avec
avec un chiffre qui est donné par la
société française d'accompagnement et de
soins palliatifs 100000 patients y
accèdent chaque année en France ça
représente selon la société française d'
accompagnement moins d'un tiers de ceux
qui en auraient besoin Denis Lab est-ce
que c'est pas là l'urgence avant de se
dire est-ce qu'il faut réformer la loi
autoriser l'ethanasie est-ce que c'est
pas mettre plus de moyens sur les mais
c'est un je dirais c'est un une panel de
solution qu'il faut trouver parce que
les malades demandent des choses
différentes il y en a qui veulent aller
soatif d'autres qui ne veulent pas il y
a d'autres qui veulent aller chez eux
mourir chez eux il y a d'autres qui
veulent rester à l'hôpital parce qu'ils
sont bien dans un service qu'il
connaissent avec les personnel donc il
faut attentendre cette variété de
demandes palliatif bien sûr il faut faut
encore que je pense qu'il serait bon que
les médecins se forment soi politif de
façon ouverte comme en Belgique c'estd
qu'il y a pas de frontière comme c'est
en France entre les soins palliatifs et
l'aide médical à mourir là il y a
vraiment un vrai problème je dirais
idéologique donc les soins palliatif oui
mais
réfléchissons tous les gens qui vont en
Belgique et en Suisse sont pas seulement
les gens qui viennent des zones il y a
pas de soins
palliatifs fa être clair ils viennent
des zones où il y a des soins palliatifs
aussi parce que ça ne correspond pas à
leur demande ouis c'est important ça
veut dire que le jour o on aura résolu
le problème des sotiv dans toute la
France et je suis pour
on n'aura pas forcément résolu le
problème de la demande des patients qui
ve vous les uns les autres là-dessus
parce que pas est-ce qu'on peut faire le
lien justement entre la qualité des
soins palliatifs et et les demandes
d'ethanasieou alors en principe non ce
sont deux sujets différents qui sont
malheureusement lié parce que le manque
de soins palliatif fait souhaiter aux
gens de pouvoir recourir à l'assistance
au suicide si ça se passe trop mal ce
sont deux sujets différents je pense que
la question d'une d'un décès anticipé mé
également assisté doit se poser quand
toutes les techniques qu'on peut
proposer enfin tous les soins qu'on peut
proposer aux patients ont échoué le
problème c'est que comme on peut pas
leur
proposer les personnes préfèrent se dire
qu'au pire elles passeront l'étape si
c'est pas possible et plutôt que
d'agoniser dans sur un lit d'hôpital
dans un couloir elle
préfère décider du moment où ça va
s'arrêter donc si j'ai bien compris vous
on devrait pas c'est tronqué le jeu est
tronqué mais mais quand même vous nous
dites s'il y a de meilleurs soins
palliatifs il y a moins de demande
d'euthanasie même si on ne devrait pas
faire ce c'est ce que disent l'ensemble
des médecins ce que disent les médecins
c'est qume important à noter c'est pour
ça ça devrait pas être lier puisque les
soins ou enfin l'assistance au suicide
ne devrait se poser
qu'après plusieurs pays on a cité la
Belgique il y a plusieurs pays d'Europe
qui autorisent l'euthanasie les Pays-Bas
vous l'avez dit la Belgique Luxembourg
Espagne en Belgique on est à près de
3000 patients qui ont eu recours à une
euthanasie en
2022 vous nous l'aveait dit Donis labal
ça représente 2,5 % des décès recensés
c'est en constante augmentation depuis
2003 le le vote de la loi seul 235
personnes l'avaient réclamé à ce
moment-là sur ce thème je vous propose
un un témoignage suis d'an Henri qui est
journaliste à à vakita réalisateur d'un
reportage euthanasie' exilé pour mourir
il est avec nous en direct bonsoir merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation vous
avez suivi des personnes qui étaient en
grande souffrance et qui donc entrepris
démarche pour aller mourir dignement en
en Belgique peut-être un peu de
pédagogie comment la procédure est-elle
encadrée en
Belgique bah en fait en Belgique il faut
trois choses d'abord il faut pouvoir
faire la demande soi-même ensuite il
faut être atteint d'une maladie grave et
incurable et il faut qu'elle entraîne
des souffrances physiques ou psychiques
inapaisables ça c'est le cadre légal de
la loi en Belgique donc ça c'est le
casadre légal ça veut dire qu'il y a
plusieurs étapes ça prend du temps il
faut aller plusieurs fois en Belgique
c'est
ça exactement nous par exemple on a
suivi le cas de Sandra Sandra elle avait
quasiment mon âge c'est-à-dire la
trentaine et elle habitait en Bretagne
et elle a dû aller deux fois en Belgique
et donc on a dû traverser toute la
France dans une petite voiture elle
pouvait même plus bouger donc voilà
c'est pour raconter un tout petit peu
les les conditions mais il faut y aller
une première fois rencontrer un médecin
euh généraliste qui réalisera
l'euthanasie plus un médecin spécialiste
ou un psychiatre euh à ce moment-là on
rédige en fait la la demande d'ethanasie
et puis normalement techniquement il
faut laisser passer un mois euh avant
l'acte en lui-même donc ça veut dire
qu'il faudra revenir une une seconde
fois merci beaucoup Alan Henry pour ce
témoignage on a en préparant l'émission
on a cherché combien ça pouvait coûter à
des Français d'aller en Belgique pour
pratiquer l'euthanasie on on trouve des
chiffres qui vont jusqu'à 5 à à 6000 €
euh Corine Ambert ça veut dire qui y a
une discrimination face à la mort seul
ceux qui ont les moyens peuvent peuvent
aller en Belgique pour pour faire ce
choix oui si est-ce que c'est pas aussi
un argument pour dire changeons la loi
j'ai pas la réponse hein oui je non
enfin pour moi CEN est pas un mais
effectivement aujourd'hui c'est une
réalité si quelqu'un qui veut avoir
recours à l'euthanasie va avoir des
frais y compris si celui qui veut avoir
recours au suicide assister se déplacer
en Suisse oui bien sûr il y a il y a des
frais et que c'est pas ouvert à à à tout
le monde euh le le paradoxe et parce
qu'on parle beaucoup de de maladie
incurable aujourd'hui tout est fait pour
que euh les patients et accès aux
médicaments innovants c'est-à-dire que
d'un côté on est en train de réfléchir à
légiférer sur euh sur le C cité ou
leutanasie vous voyez on parle des deux
sujets alors que je pense que dans
l'idée du président de la République on
n'allait pas jusqu'à l'euthanasie c'est
pour ça que je pense qu'il tarde à à à à
donner le feu vert pour le texte parce
qu'il a peut-être peur que ça ça lui
échappe d'un côté on fait tout pour euh
permettre re que des maladies incurables
aujourd'hui soit des maladies qu'on
soigne demain faut bien le reconnaître
on fait pas assez pour les soins
palliatifs et oui pour répondre à votre
question bien sûr il y a un coup il est
c'est un fait donc on peut paser il faut
noter quand même qu'en Belgique le
contrôle de la procédure se fait à
postériori c'estàdire que même si le
cheminement n'a pas été bien fait de
toute façon la personne est décédée
quand le contrôle est fait par la
commission den Lab quand même est-ce que
le j'allais dire l'offre crée sa propre
demande c'est horrible sur quand on
parle de de de ça mais en même temps
c'est aussi un peu un business dans les
pays qui ont légalisé l'euthanasie donc
est-ce que on peut dire ça par exemple
de la Belgique le fait d'avoir voté
cette loi ben voilà régulièrement le le
nombre de patients qui viennent en Belgi
pratiqué mais vous et même s'il augmente
où est le problème je veux dire s'il
reste dans des proportions tout à fait
raisonnables où est le problème je pense
qu'il y a de plus en plus de gens qui
prennent conscience de la chose ou je
crois que ça ça ne me choque pas si vous
voulez on a 2,5 % 4 % de la population
ça reste très faible et puis je dirais
c'est le choix des gens je vois pas
pourquoi on interviendrait pour leur
dire ben non ça ça dépasse le quota
qu'on a prévu et puis les soins
palliatifs ne répondent pas à tout ça
c'est chose importante à le dire la
morphine c'est un très bon produit ça
soulage dans 80 % des cas très bien mais
dans 20 % des cas vous avez des
difficultés à manipuler la morphine
c'est pas simple et puis les soin
palliatifs ne règl pas le problème des
maladies neurodégénératives Valérie de P
oui mais notre président a dit il y a
quelques mois maintenant qu'il
souhaitait qu'on lui propose un modèle
français de la fin de vie et je pense
qu'un modèle français c'est un modèle
qui va exclure de toute façon toutes les
questions financières comme l'assistance
médicale à la procréation en France par
exemple alors que que c'est aussi un
business dire que tout le monde sera
égal face c'est pour ça voilà ce ça veut
dire quelque chose un modèle français ça
veut dire respecter les grands principes
qui fond notre droit notamment notre
droit médical ou
biomédical respect de la dignité
consentement et exclusion de toute
valeur marchande on le fait pour la vie
je pense qu'on le fera pour la mort on
peut l'espérer alors justement ce modèle
français à quoi pourrait-il ressembler
je propose à à Quentin Calmet de nous
rejoindre tout de suite puisque il y a
effectivement un texte qui est en
préparation depuis un certain nombre de
mois qui est aujourd'hui qui est prêt
que contient ce texte Quentin et bien
c'est dur à dire exactement car il
manque toujours les derniers arbitrage
au sommet de l'exécutif donc difficile
de savoir à l'heure où l'on se parle ce
que va contenir le projet de effectiv
êre saisi le Parlement dans les
prochaines semaines dans les prochains
mois mais dans le monde on a lu que le
texte serait composé de plusieurs
partiesagirait d'abord de développer les
soins palliatifs rebaptisés d'ailleurs
soins d'accompagnement car on le
rappelle en France seul un tiers des
patients concernés disposeent d'un accès
à ses soins contre la douleur autre
volet majeur et qui fait toujours
l'objet de d'une attente d'arbitrage
c'est celui qui vise le volet qui vise à
ouvrir l'accès à l'aide à mourir sous
certaines conditions le patient pourrait
alors se voir prescrire un produit létal
sous réserve d'une décision médicale
collégiale Thomas évidemment c'est la
question centrale sous quelle condition
cette aide à mourir pourrait-elle
intervenir voici les pistes qui sont
avancées pour l'heure le patient
devrait-être atteint d'une maladie
incurable avoir un pronostic vital
engagé avec des souffrances physiques
insupportables la personne ne devrait
être dotée d'une volonté libre et
éclairer si elle veut pas se donner la
mort physiquement alors et bien le
projet de loi pourrait permettre
intervention d'un professionnel de santé
ou d'un proche mais bien entendu toutes
ces définitions essentielles elles sont
en négociation au sein même de
l'exécutif Emmanuel Macron qui hésite
visiblement Thomas seule vraie piste
pour l'instant a priori écarté l'idée de
passer par le référendum pour aller vers
ce projet de loi cette piste avait
pourtant été évoquée par Emmanuel Macron
lui-même en avril 2022 afin de trancher
cette question de société mais on sent
désormais une réticence au sein du
gouvernement écoutez la ministre en
charge de ce dossier agès firmain le
budau sur notre antenne c'était il y a
15 jours sur un sujet comme celui-là
j'ai la question à poser à répondre par
oui ou par non n'est pas si simple que
ça est-ce que on parle juste d'une
évolution du CP de du du principe parce
que c'est un sujet de société c'est
clairement un sujet de société et les
nombreux débats que je fais auquels je
participe et encore et je vais encore en
continuer à faire vois bien me montre à
quel point je crois que la société est
vraiment paste à évoluer mais tout le
monde s'interroge et c'est légitime
enfin je voulais évoquer une dernière
piste que l'on dont on parle en coulisse
c'est l'idée de proposer au Parlement un
texte à minima sans l'aide active à
mourir et laisser députés et sénateurs
trouver un équilibre sur le projet de
loi lorsqu'il arrivera au Parlement
merci beaucoup Quentin alors je me
tourne évidemment vers vous Corine
est-ce que vous c'est ce que vous
demandez finalement que que ce texte
soit soit quasiment écrit par les
parlementaires sans qu'on vous donne là
une ligne directrice trop rigide
connaissez l'attachement du par
oui mais non mais c'est on pourrait dire
aussi que le Président de la République
vous pardon c'est très trivial ce que je
dire mais vous refile la patate Chae
quoi vous voyez c'est-être ce qui lui
fait peur aussi c'est peut-être ce qui
lui fait peur je pense que c'est pour ça
qu'on a pas le texte à l'heure qu'il est
on devait l'avoir avant la fin de l'été
on voit bien les les les les hésitations
et et ça s'entend le sujet est difficile
saboè vous l'avez rappelé les sondages
vont en faveur d'une aide active à
mourir pour
autant la la la la discussion et même si
un sujet sociétal difficile c'est quand
même lui qui l'a mis sur la table je
pense que il sait plus comment s'en
sortir il y il y a quand même il y a
dans dans ce texte on vient de le voir
avec Quentin il y a à la fois le
développement des soins palliatifs et
puis la question de de l'aide à mourir
il y a un collectif qui représente
plusieurs centaines de milliers de
professionnels de santé qui s'est dit
choqué par ce mélange des genres deis
Lab est-ce que vous aussi ça vous choque
que ce soit dans le même texte ben non
je pense que c'est absolument
indispensable que ce soit dans texte sûr
pourquoi vous savez parce que c'est le
problème de la fin de vie la fin de vie
sa Sissonne pas on a tendance à voir les
problèmes les un après les autres ration
palliative d'un côté il y a ceci non le
malade choisit c'est lui qui est le
maître de la situation ça il faut bien
se le mettre dans la tête et je suis
très étonné pour juste pour reprendre ce
que vous dites que le Président de la
République n'est pas saisi la situation
qui a eu au mois d'avril 1900 2021 où il
y a eu au Parlement la le projet dans
une niche parlementaire de de Olivier
alor n où tous les parlementaires se
sont levés il lui ont fait une ovation
debout il y a eu que 40 personnes qui
étaient contre il y a eu 4000
amendements il avait l'occasion rêveré
pour laisser le Parlement continuer à
travailler et je n'ai pas compris
personnellement pourquoi on n' pas été
au-delà alors justement on va essayer
d'analyser ça avec vous laéticia je vous
propose d'abord d'écouter le président
de de la République on est juste après
la convention citoyenne parce qu'il a
aussi convoqué une c'était une promesse
de campagne d'uel Macron et puis ensuite
il y a eu cette convention citoyenne sur
la fin de vie on écoute Emmanuel Macron
je demande au gouvernement en lien avec
les parlementaires désignés par le
président du Sénat et la présidente de
l'Assemblée national qui avec leur
conférence des présidents auront à faire
ce travail
transpartisan de mener une œuvre de
coconstruction sur la base de cette
référence solide qui est celle de la
convention citoyenne et en lien avec
toutes les parties
prenante je souhaite que ce travail
permette de bâtir un projet de loi d'ici
à la fin de l'été 2023
fin de l'été 2023 évidemment bon voilà
on a on est quelques mois plus tard
pourquoi laéticia Emmanuel Macron
tardent-il à donner son feu vert la
nouvelle échéance il l'a donné c'est la
fin du mois de décembre donc c'est dans
quelques semaines pourquoi il tarde
écoutez c'est la question que se pose
toute la majorité Thomas on ne comprend
pas pourquoi Emmanuel Macron
terregiverse alors qu'il a le texte de
Madame fmain lebudau la Ministre chargée
des professions de santé depuis 2 mois
presque sur sur son bureau et elle
attend voilà Agnès firmanobodo elle
attend depuis plusieurs mois d'avoir un
un projet de loi à défendre donc
peut-être première piste que je vous
propose le timing ça va être comp
compliqué comme je vous disais avant la
fin décembre quand on interroge l'isée
il dit pourtant tous disent ce sera fin
décembre or le 13 décembre il faut quand
même qu'il y ait laav du Conseil d'État
le 13 décembre il y a l'inscription de
dans la Constitution donc il reste la
date du 20 décembre est-ce que c'est une
bonne date juste avant Noël pour un
projet sur la fin de vie pas si sûr et
puis il y a aussi la forme Thomas qui
freinerait le président est-ce que on
est encore en train de se demander s'il
faut parler de suicide assisté ou
d'euthanasie et ça a fait l'objet
notamment d'une passe d'armes dans la
dernière réunion interministérielle sur
le sujet la semaine dernière apparemment
qui a été mouvementé parce que il y a
encore des résistances dans la majorité
par exemple la ministre des solidarités
et des familles Aurore berger est contre
une nouvelle loi et elle fait partie de
ce camp qui pense que la loi actuelle
suffit si elle est bien appliquée et
laisse beaucoup de possibilité alors il
y a des résistances internes dans sa
majorité et puis Emmanuel Macron craint
peut-être aussi la réaction d'autorité
morale c'est ce qui se murmure en tout
cas dans son cercle très proche
c'est-à-dire qu'il a reçu plusieurs
responsables religieux et tous le
dernier en date c'est vraiment il y a
pas très longtemps c'était le grand
Rabin aim Corscia tous sont contre et
donc ça freinerait encore une fois le
président de la République mais on l'a
dit c'était l'une de ses promesses de de
candidat il veut quand même proposer une
loi un chantier pour la fin de son
quinquéa c'est là que le bas blesse
parce que selon mes sources qui sont
diverses variés proches du pouvoir elles
sont toutes unanimes Emmanuel Macron
dans le fond serait contre une évolution
de la loi contre une nouvelle loi et
Brigitte Macron son épouse également je
vous parle là de leur intime conviction
hein donc évidemment ce sera jamais mis
à jour la question qui se pose c'est
est-ce qu'Emmanuel Macron finalement a
lancé ce chantier parce que vous le
disiez tout à l'heure 9 Français sur 10
le volulent est-ce qu'il l'a fait parce
que c'était c'était poussé par le peuple
et c'est un casus Bell pour Emmanuel
Macron finalement et c'est pour ça qu'il
tergiverse la question qu'il se posose
elle est simple faut-il faire cette loi
pour répondre à une demande populaire
alors que lui-même est intimement
convaincu du contraire et je vous
propose encore cette question de façon
un peu plus large en guise de conclusion
de mon édito dans un régime
présidentiel un président peut-il lancer
un chantier aussi fondamental que celui
de la fin de vie alors que lui-même est
contre voir et pétri de doute ouais ça
ça pose une question qui est on parlait
de pouvoir den label est-ce que c'est la
décision d'un seul homme parce qu'on a
l'impression que c'est c'est on est dans
ce moment on est dans ce moment
particulier le dessin de ce texte dépend
de de d'un seul homme le présent de la
République alors qu'il a eu la
Convention sur la fin de vie alors qu'il
y a eu beaucoup de consultations auprès
de la ministre et cetera et on oublie un
petit peu que nous sommes dans une
République laïque pour moi laïque ça
veut dire tolérance c'estàdire qu'on
tolère les religions toutes les
religions et ceux qui ne sont pas
croyants or si on nétudie pas le
problème de la fin de vie à la lumière
de la laïcité en effet on tombe dans les
blocs idéologique et à ce moment-là on
se laisse influencer par l'un ou par
l'autre non et on est dans une
république il faut étudier voilà
qu'est-ce qui correspond à la liberté à
l'égalité et à la fraternité il n'est
pas normal que le pouvoir religieux en
l'occurrence pèse de tout son poids dans
l'évolution de cette loi c'est son droit
de se manifester c'est son tout à fait
sa responsabilité de dire ce qu'il pense
mais il doit en Belgique ils se sont
retirés de du débat ils ont dit voilà
nous av don notre avis maintenant c'est
à la société de se prononcer et la
France reste tout même avec un poids
religieux multi religieux très lourd moi
j'ai été au repas du président de la
République j'étais le seul par rapport à
tous les représentants des religions
monothéistes qui tout étai d'accord du
reste c'est extraordinaire c'est la
première fois que j'ai vu toutes les
religions monothéistes sur un même point
d'accord
mais voilà je pense que nous sommes dans
une République laïque ouverte et ça il
faudrait que le Président de la
République ne l'oublie pas alors ce
poids des religions il s'exprime
notamment l'église catholique je vous
propose de d'entendre Éric de moulin
Beaufort qui préside la Conférence des
évêques de c'était le 8 novembre dernier
lors de leur assemblée plainère nous
lançons un appel pour redire notre
inquiétude non moins grande devant le
projet de loi en préparation concernant
la fin de vie une société humaine doit
être fraternelle pour tous et pour
toutes jusqu'à la fin de la vie et
promouvoir l'aide active à vivre tout en
se gardant d'un certain goût pour la
mort inhérent à notre humanité marquée
par le péché
emmanel Macron a également rencontré le
pape François à plusieurs reprises la
dernière fois c'était à à à
Marseille à la fin de de l'été Corine
Ambert est-ce qu'il cède au aux
arguments finalement
de des religieux des religions
monothéistes et notamment de l'Église
catholique Emmanuel Macron je sais pas
si c'est toutes les religions sont
exprimées nous avons auditionné dans le
cadre de notre mission au Sénat elles
ont effectivement été unanime et sont
pronosé compte pour autant elle ne
participe pas au vote demain si le texte
sera est déb B au au au Sénat par contre
je pense qu'il a ses propres convictions
et qu'il est piégé et il est piégé par
la Convention citoyenne parce que il a
déjà fait la convention coyenne sur
l'environnement il a reçu 150 et quel
propositions il en a retenu une faire
une autre organisation tout à fait vrai
mais bon c'est pas grave je vous laisse
la responsabilité de de ratiogan mais
c'est ce qu' enfin il il il a il a il
organise une autre convention citoyenne
s'il avait pas été à l'écoute on lui aur
dit à quoi bon organiser des conventions
citoyennes bien ça ne sert à rien le
peuple n'est pas écouté ouais même si
contrairement à ce qui été dit elle a
pas complètement été tir au sort c'est
2000 personnes qui ont été tir au sort
parmi les 2000 les 150 ou 170 ont été
choisis aussi mais il il est piégé il
est piégé par sa promesse il est piégé
par la Convention citoyenne et ça
correspond pas à ses convictions alors
oui est-ce que le pouvoir c'est le choix
de un homme ses convictions personnelles
c'est pour ça qu' il arrive pas et je
pense qu'ensuite l'autre piège qui peut
l'attendre
c'est le vote du Parlement et de ce que
sera le texte sorti du Parlement oui et
après je veux bien vous entendre sur ce
que vient de de nous dire den la sur le
le la République laïque est-ce que le
poids finalement des des religions n'est
pas trop important dans une République
laïque dans un débat comme celui-là par
raort à la laïcité la laïité n'exclut
pas non plus les religions ah ben non
non voilà alors est-ce qu'il est trop
important pas assez important mais en
tout cas pourquoi pourquoi ne les
pourquoi ne pas les auditionner pourquoi
ne pas écouter leur avis je dis pas
qu'il faut pas lesitionner la question
c'est est-ce qu'il pèse pas trop voilà
c'est ce que je reprends l'argument
de parmi les arguments justement de de
l'Église catholique que j'ai pu trouver
là en préparant l'émission cet
après-midi il y a il y a cette idée Val
de dire attention on est dans une
extension du domaine de la violence
légitime qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'on
peut répondre ça non je pense pas qu'il
s'agit d'une violence voilà pour moi la
violence n'a pas n'a pas la place dans
le dans le raisonnement la violence
ressentie par les personnes c'est pas
être entendu d'une façon ou d'une autre
pas être respectter dans leur volonté
dans dans leur
personne ce qui est violent c'est de pas
pouvoir accéder à des soins palliatifs
quand on en a besoin ça c'est violent
oui mais sinon non d'ailleurs il y a une
question dire oui je crois que c'est un
texte qui va être particulièrement
difficile à écrire parce qu'il suffit
pas d'acter la volonté des Français 9/
10 ça tout le monde l'a compris mais il
va falloir l'acter dans la grille de
notre droit et de nos de nos grands
principes déjà c'est ce dont on parlait
tout à l'heure et il y a une chose dont
on n pas parlé c'est que ça se fera pas
sans les médecins voilà com il va bien
falloir trouver un consensus
oui tous les méde accepont d'cpagner le
disent j mais ceux qui refusent vont
aller chercher les autres non on va pas
faire des des autanator enfin je veux
dire c'est c'est pas les médecins qui
acceptent d'accompagner leurs patients
qui accepteront d'accompagner tous les
patients alors qu'est-ce qu'on va faire
on va construire des endroit plus on va
pas non plus sanctionner les médecins
qui refuser de la du tout je dis juste
que c'est très complié très difficile
maintenant on trouvera je compte sur
vous je vis juste vous dire une chose la
violence c'est la maladie c'est ça la
violence c'est la souffrance c'est ce
qu'on soit au jour le jour c'est ça
qu'on est obligé de
traiter le le allez-y ouais non mais et
puis si toutefois le texte était dans le
sens d'une AAC qui à mourir après on le
voit dans d'autres dans d'autres pays
c'est c'est les
extensions des
situations qui correspondrai pour les
patients à la possibilité de de demander
cette ad qui va mourir là vous l'avez vu
des personnes majeures mais la question
de de l'aide Activ mourir chez des
mineurs se pose et et existe dans dans
certains pays voyez et on met un pied et
puis jusqu'où ça s'arrête moi j'avais
été frappé lors de nos auditions par un
philosophe qui nous a mais les choses
sont assez simples il suffit de
légiférer dans trois grandes situation
et dans
l'ordre les personnes lourdement
handicapées les personnes atintes
maladie incurbl et l'extrême vieillesse
voyez que on parle plus que de maladie
incurable on voit tout de suite vers
quoi ça pourrait ouvrir donc vous dites
attention à une dérive potentielle
qu'estce r ben je dis que les dérives
elles sont aujourd'hui là parce que on
parle toujours de dérive possible de
l'aide active à mourir on ne parle pas
d' dérive de la vie coûte que
coûte l'affaire alin coq qui est depuis
36 ans grabataire et on lui dit non
monsieur il faut attendre encore un
petit peu ce sont des dérives de ceux
qui soutiennent la vie coûte que coûte
et ça on n parle pas mais c'est
épouvantable on oublie de dire qu'on pas
la demande de ses patients al justement
il est mort en 2021 par suicide assisté
il a dû aller en Suisse effectivement 35
ans d'une maladie incurable il avait
écrit une lettre non seulement au
présent République mais aussi au
gouvernement parlementair français et il
avait été interviewé par la FP 2 mois
avant sa mort je vous propose l' dans
les f depuis 50 ans on le on leur
enseigne que la mort est un échec du
MIN c'est pas le cas ça fait partie du
cycle de la vie le cycle de la vie n'est
pas un
échec le rôle d'un médecin c'est
d'accompagner le patient dans ses
pathologies de le guérir quand il le
peut et de soulager quand il ne peut
plus Val de je va vous laisser le mot de
la conclusion il nous reste 30 secondes
vous avez parlé des médecins ça ne se
fera pas sans les médecins est-ce qu'il
faut aussi les former un peu
différemment sur ces questions
certainement certainement maintenant
pour ce qui est des dérives
je suis sans doute naïve mais je fais
assez confiance à à notre système à
notre système juridique qui notamment en
bioéthique en biomédecine a déjà fait
ses preuves donc je pense qu'on trouvera
un modèle français merci beaucoup on va
terminer sur cette note optimiste je
rappelle Denis labal le titre de votre
livre le médecin la liberté et la mort
livre qui est publié aux éditions plomb
voilà c'est la fin de ce sens public je
vous dis à bientôt sur sur Public Sénat
et puis notez que demain l'invité de la
matinale Doriane monsini sera le général
Dominique trinquant l'ancien chef de la
mission militaire française auprès de
l'ONU bonne soirée à toutes et à tous
[Musique]
merci allez on va la tourner tout le
monde en place et action Michel c'était
votre programme avec yomoni et Michel
PAREF qui ne serait pas là s'il avait
mieux géré son épargne et je fais quoi
[Musique]
là voir ou revoir votre
programme sur
publsena.fr les nouvelles de l'attentat
dans le grand magasin Tati trois
personnes auraient été tuées par le
commando il est 17h05 hier PL Charles de
Gaulle une bombe explose lorsque il y a
eu les attentats de Charlie et aussi
ceux sur l'hyper cach ch aussi sur la
policière de Montrouge il y a eu un
soulèvement
j'ordonne que tous les moyens soi
employés partout ils ne passeront pas en
ce qui concerne le terroristes la
réponse c'est l'unité nationale vous
avez une rage c'est l'inhumanité la
barbarie le terrorisme ne détruira pas
la République car c'est la République
qui le détruira président le a payé face
au terrorisme un documentaire inédit
écrit par Michel cota et Patrice duamel
réalisé par Pauline per vendredi à 22h
sur Public Sénat et dès à présent sur
[Musique]
publicsenat.fr promixité vous est
présenté par NG acteur engagé en faveur
de ité
professionnelle bonjour à tous et
bienvenue dans promixité l'émission qui
vous parle de la place des femmes dans
le monde du travail aujourd'hui focus
sur l'égalité hommes-femme et la Cour
des comptes qui pour la première fois
s'empare de ce sujet avec un rapport
particulièrement sévère à l'égard de
l'État et pourtant on s'en souvient
Emmanuel Macron l'avait érigé en grande
cause nationale lors de son premier
quinquena avec tout un tas de plans
interministériels qui se superposent
sans véritable coordination nous disent
les sages de la rue Cambon les sages qui
le reprochent notamment un manque de
diagnostic de moyens et de calendrier
rendant toute évaluation impossible le
nouveau plan interministériel pour
l'égalité hommes-femmes mériterait lui
aussi d'être amélioré avec un calendrier
de suivi effectif en